One use case for generators is
the ability to do waterfall-like
ajax requests. You've probably
run into a situation before
where you first need to hit an
ajax request where you search
for something, and then when
that search comes back, it maybe
gives you a user ID. Given
that ID, you have to hit a
second ajax request based on
that ID. When that comes back,
maybe you get a list of photos
for that user, and you need
specific information about the
first photo, or something that
came back based on that photo ID.
These are like waterfall, one,
two, three. We need the
information from the previous
one in order to do the next one.
You know that that can lead to
what's called the callback hell,
where you have nested code
inside of each other.
There's libraries like async
that are really good for dealing
with that, however the browser
is getting much better at being
able to do it natively. We're
going to look at an example of
how you can do it with
generators. What I want to do
is make a function called steps.
This is going to be a generator
itself, so we have to put an
asterisk after the word function.
By the way, you can also put an
asterisk in front of the
function name. Either will work,
it's just a personal preference.
What I want to do here is that
I've got three ajax requests
that I'm going to be making here.
I've got one that's going to go
fetch me a list of beers, one
that's going to go fetch my
information from GitHub and one
that's going to go fetch
information about the artist Fat
Joe. Assume that these relied
on each other -- they don't
really, but I just want to make
one ajax request, when that
comes back I want the second one,
and I want the third one.
Would you believe me if I were
to say that we could write this
code in one line, just like this,
and that it would execute, stop,
execute, stop, execute and stop?
That's actually how it's going
to work. What I've done here
is I've yielded. I've created a
variable called beers. I've
yielded whatever the result of
ajax. We're going to create a
function called ajax, and only
once that ajax function returns
a value, will the next one run.
Only once that ajax request
returns my GitHub info, it's
going to come back and run the
next one. We're going to be
able to write code that's very
nice and clean, top-to-bottom
here, without having to worry
about callbacks or promises or
anything like that. We'll go
up here and make that ajax
function. That's going to be
called ajax, and it's going to
take in a URL. Inside of that
function we'll say fetch the URL.
When that comes back, we are
going to get the data and return
thedata.json. You'll know from
our previous ones that that also
returns a promise which we call .
thenOn which we have the data
that gives it back. What do
we then do with this data once
we have it? Once we have the
data, essentially what we want
to do is call next on this
generator that we're going to
create. We need to create the
generator down here, so we'll
say, const datagen = steps. Then
what we're going to say is go up
here and say datagen.next, and
pass it the data. This is a
little bit confusing, so bear
with me a second. What's
happening here is that, on page
load, we are going to create a
brand new generator and call it
datagen. This is the generator
we've created right here.
Then I'm going to call the first
one, just to kick it off,
otherwise it won't run its first
one. Datagen.next. We'll put a
comment there, "kick it off."
What will happen is when you
kick it off, the first one is
going to run. It's going to
request ajax. We're going to go
here, it's going to fetch this
URL. When the data comes back to
us, we're going to call next.
Next is on our generator that we
created. The cool thing
about this here is that whatever
we pass from next will go back
to the generator and get stored
in this initial variable.
It's really cool, because you
create this variable beers, and
then even if this takes 10
minutes or 10 hours, the result
of this yield is going to get
put back into the variable beers.
Then next is going to run, so
the next yield will run here,
where we'll run an ajax request.
That might take five seconds,
five minutes, who knows? When
that comes back, we're going to
get the Fat Joe one. Let's
take a look at how it works. I'm
going to put some comments above
here. Console.log fetching beers,
and then console.log beers when
we're done. Console.log fetching
Wes, console.log Wes,
console.log fetching Fat Joe,
and console.log Fat Joe. Now
when I give this a refresh,
we'll see where we're at,
fetching beers comes back. Oh,
that went nice and fast.
Fetching beers took a second,
and then when the beers came
back it stored it in a variable
called beers, console.logged it,
moved along to save fetching Wes
Bos, made that second request
here to go fetch my information
from GitHub. When that one came
back, fetching Fat Joe came back,
run the ajax request, and came
back. That's really nice top-
to-bottom, very readable code.
The only thing that you need to
know is that we must call the
next on our actual generator
that gets called, and pass it
the actual data, and that will
put it inside of there.
That's really nice because if I
wanted to maybe see if there's a
beers...I could put the beers
name inside of here. Obviously
there's not a GitHub name with
that beer, but if I needed the
data from this first one in the
second request, I could have
easily done that because this
code will not run until this one
comes back. Hopefully that
helped you understand a little
bit more about generators.